Think that Donald Trump is a better president
than Abraham Lincoln.
There is a new economist you gov Paul from
right around Thanksgiving and it's a normal
poll where they ask about many things.
They ask about presidential approval, opinions
of items in the news, but then it has something
very interesting and it asks how do you see
Trump versus past presidents?
And this is a real insight into Trumpist minds.
And it also relates to some cognitive biases
that are important to understand.
So this will be useful.
Voters were asked which Republican was a better
president, Donald Trump or Abraham Lincoln?
Most demographic groups, no matter how you
slice it, we're pretty evenly United that
Lincoln was a better president.
If you look at men and women, men and women,
roughly equally mid seventies to mid twenties
believe Lincoln was a better president, okay?
When you look at different income groups,
people earning under 50,000 between 50 and
a hundred thousand and more than a hundred
thousand roughly by the same three to one
margin, they view Lincoln as the better president
than Donald Trump.
But when you look at party identification,
Republicans by 53 to 47 margin believe that
Donald Trump is a better president than Abraham
Lincoln.
Now, as a side note, before we continue, Republicans
also think Trump is a way better president
than George W. Bush by 71 to 29 margin, which
is stunning.
And again, George W. Bush was no angel, truly,
but Trump.
Incredible.
But let's discuss what's going on here because
there's evidence of a few different things.
Number one, there is a blinding ideology for
some where they truly see Trump as the best
without applying any real critical thinking
to the question of Lincoln versus Trump.
They just say, Trump's better.
For others it's ignorance.
They don't really know what Lincoln did, so
Trump is better in their minds.
It's a combination of ignorance plus lack
of critical thinking.
For others, they actually don't like Lincoln
because he freed the slaves and it was on
the side of the union in the civil war.
You can see this when you look at the regionalized
results, we're in the South.
The numbers are most skewed against Lincoln
and towards Trump and then there are just
some sort of general cognitive biases at play.
There's the recency bias.
That's where a person more easily remembers
recent events compared to something that occurred
a while back that will skew results.
This would suggest that any poll about the
current president versus a president hundreds
of years ago would be skewed towards the current
president to some degree because of recency
bias.
Then you also have the availability bias,
which is kind of implicit in what I already
told you.
This is the human tendency to think of examples
more easily of things that happened recently
and to imagine that they are representative
in a group to a greater degree than they are.
So if you can think of more things Trump did
that you like compared to Lincoln, you extrapolate
and you say, well, Trump is better on that
basis because I can remember more things that
Donald Trump did.
So this is about many things.
It is in part about the ideologically blinded,
ignorant Republicans.
It's also about the cult of personality around
Donald Trump.
But there are some general cognitive biases
at play as well.
What I believe this points to as a strategy,
and I know I'm a broken record on this, you
can't argue with people who think Trump is
better than Lincoln and rationally explain
to them why they should vote for someone else.
Let's not even try that as a way to win in
2020 I told you earlier in the show when we
watched video of that totally delusional Trump
supporter who said, I love Trump because he's
honest and he has integrity and he has family
values.
You can't argue with that.
If someone has a disagreement on tax policy
and they like Trump's tax policy, we might
be able to have a conversation.
When someone is so diluted and disconnected
from reality, the arguments are a waste of
time.
We're better off getting out the vote.
We're better off finding people who are already
on our side but might not care enough to vote
or might not think their vote is important.
Those are the folks that we want to be going
after trying to change the minds of someone
who loves Trump's family values or thinks
Trump is a better president than Lincoln.
It's a waste of time.
It's not going to win the November of 2020
election for us.
Let me know what you think.
Leave a reply.
If you're watching on YouTube, send me a tweet
at Dee Pacman.
We will take a quick break and then talk about
interesting news out of Google and YouTube.
I also have some book recommendations
or are you an excellent, excellent voicemail?
Leger with us on this first show back after
the Thanksgiving holiday,